what advice would Jocko give his
seventeen year old self regarding school
social relationships parents peer
pressure etc yes like the actual Jocko
podcast tonight all these questions are
about a job yeah okay that's kind of
what I was asking like outside of the
military yeah you know if I was gonna
tell myself something here's a couple
things that you know I would tell myself
too did you hatch I tell myself to learn
that I would tell myself that that girl
isn't the whole world yeah and it was
friends aren't the last friends you're
ever gonna have and the party isn't
gonna be the best party of all time and
all those things that you think is what
we talked about earlier all those things
that you think are a huge deal when
you're young they're not a big deal and
I know that's kind of messed up but it's
true man
it's true the things that you think are
a big deal when you're 17 years old yeah
not that big of a deal and it's really
hard to convince someone that seventeen
years old of that right yeah
they also also what they don't recognize
is things that are a big deal they don't
recognize they think they're a little
deal right so they're doing stupid
things right yeah whether it's drinking
and driving whether I mean kids still
drink and drive now like yeah how dumb
is that
yeah and so people don't think you know
nowadays we've talked about social media
are easy but people post stuff on social
media and you come and you know I've
heard now you know we work with a lot of
different companies when you apply for a
job they go and look at your social
media and see what kind of an idiot you
might be hey that's a good movement no
it's a great move it's a great move
so yeah just just recognize that some of
the little things are actually big and
some of the big things are actually
little and I'd square those things away
and the unsaid this before when you're
young you've got to realize that how you
act now is directly related to your
future success to your future happiness
to your future financial situation to
everything so so it's hard to make that
connection right we are young impossible
it might be impossible some kids get it
though I'm telling you some kids get it
I think they're just no some kids get it
some
of my oldest daughters friends they get
it like they're on track yeah they're on
track they're like hey I'm doing this
I'm doing that they're on track they're
16 years old they're studying for the
SATs they're taking the AP classes
my daughter included like they're on
track to make stuff happen yeah but I
think and I'm nothing this is the case
but this is probably the case one way or
another I could be wrong man but okay so
and we talked about this before you in
that part of your brain that understands
all that that you're talking about
that's near develop develop so this is
you know and this is from what I
understand how you kind of influence
people you just put them on a routine
kind of like okay so is the difference
between understanding like what I'm
doing now and having it tangible no
untested I know where you're going with
us and your UI I believe that there are
definitely some kids like that that are
just they're just like hey okay I'm
supposed to get good grades may be all
that track I know for a fact kids that
are like no I am going to do this this
this and it's gonna leave me here
actually you know what you're right cuz
this is good Blake you know remember
Blake I used to do videos for ya um so
he we did like a thing where it was I
think he's like a Q&A or something like
that and he was he was talking about
that where in elementary school he
remembers feeling like if if I don't
have perfect attendance and have perfect
straight A's
I won't pass this not pass but I won't
like be the the perfect guy or whatever
and he said that he would you would like
create like this track to his whole
future and his life would be ruined
that's how it felt like whoa so I'm
living like literally minutes a minute
and the reason I wanted to do my
homework and get good grades is so I
wouldn't get in trouble straight
straight not to get into college you
were sure none of that stuff for sure
and then that's the way most kids are in
my opinion most kids aren't hey I don't
want to get in trouble some immediate
repercussions myself included yeah hey I
gotta pass this so I can go to the next
grade yeah and stuff yeah or I don't
want to be the guy in class who didn't
do his homework you know kind of thing
yeah
but yeah I guess so
yeah I guess so that's that's me trying
to I got a step outside myself on that
one and I guess the final thing
obviously I tell myself discipline
equals freedom which is basically what
we're saying yeah so get this wonderin
how you live your life yeah I think the
biggest one there is to whether they
totally understand that or not say like
what you're doing right right now is the
important things in life the things that
you think are important or not are not
important and then things that aren't
that you think are not important are
important so it's kind of like a like an
iceberg you know I'll be old you know
the people that watch over that little
statement you know why cuz people really
like the way you say important you just
said eight times the flurry of glory and
and rainbows emojis yes I agree with you
so like the iceberg thing you know you
know the iceberg metaphor where it's
like people only see the top of the
iceberg
below that is like this huge iceberg so
that's what that's what important things
are in life right so you think it's just
this little small little iceberg but
when you think of the whole scope of
life would you have no access to it by
the way as yet it's that whole iceberg
you know so if you're not focusing on
that important part of the iceberg well
I guess an iceberg situation is not that
important but yeah another metaphor but
it'll sink your ship yeah yeah you know
they like in that kind of situation um
but and then at the same time the things
that aren't really important meaning
they don't have an iceberg under there
they're just little floaty thing you
think that's so important that thing's
gonna melt or get crowded or whatever
you know not gonna thank you no it's not
gonna thank you it's just kind of it's
fleeting